Lately there's been a huge growth
in using infrared structured light.
All right, and infrared structured
light, one of the nice things about it
is you and I can't see it, so
it's doing all this stuff out there but
it's not,
sort of interfering with our vision.
And the main reason,
that IR structured light has become so
big is because of this puppy right here,
the Microsoft Kinect, all right?
Kudos to my friends and colleagues
in in England and Cambridge who
helped take the technology, and it was,
the 3-D technology that I'll tell
you about was actually developed by
PrimeSense which was a Israel company.
And then Microsoft leveraged
it in a way to go from
the depth to recovering skeleton,
which is a whole other interesting piece
of work that we won't talk about here.
But if we did it in machine learning,
since they used machine
learning methods for
doing it,
we could talk more about doing that.
But the Kinect is really, I mean it was
$150, so all of a sudden you could put
depth sensors on little experimental
robots for very little money.
So, how does the Kinect work?
Well, it's not public, all right?
So there are people who know
exactly how the Kinect works,
people from PrimeSense,
etc., but it's not public.
Lots and lots of this stuff is known.
But the exact implementations
are not known.
The PrimeSense patents
describe at least two ways.
And I will tell you about
both of those ways.
Conventional wisdom is that one of
the ways is actually used in the Kinect
and one is not.
I don't really care,
they're both kind of interesting.
So, the two methods, that they use,
one is a very, very clever optics trick.
In fact, it's so clever I don't totally
understand exactly how it works,
because I have to get more into detail.
But essentially, it projects a pattern
with two different kinds of lenses, and
we'll talk more about it in a minute,
that allows you to go directly
from the image to the depth.
We'll explain that.
And then the much more standard way,
which is just like light striping,
is that you're essentially using
something about the projected image from
the projection of a particular pattern,
and
what it's observed like in the,
in the other camera.
So, you're about to see some
drawings that look kind of funky.
They don't look like, you know,
the high quality drawings that
Megan always insists that I use.
But that's because these are actually
taken directly from the patent and
the patent applications.
I think it's cool to just see those.
So the key to the Kinect sorry,
the key to PrimeSense focus method
are these cylindrical lenses.
So cylindrical lenses,
if you take two of them and
you have one that goes one way and
I think on the next thing,
you have one goes the other way, you
end up with this funny situation where
you have different focal lengths
depending upon which way you move.
So you have a,
one focal length horizontally and
a different focal length vertically,
and of course,
slightly different focal length as
you were to sort of, rotate around.
What this allows them to do is
to project out speckles, and
they, now,
what happens when a dot is out of focus?
Well, in a normal lens, right,
it becomes a blurry circle.
When you have one of these,
what are called, astigmatic or asym,
asymmetric lenses, it becomes
an ellipse because the, the lenses
are different in one direction than
they are in another direction.
And what's cool about the way
they did this geometry, and
this is the part that I'd have to work
through the math more to understand,
is that depending upon the depth,
so here the hand is at one z and
here is at another z,
again these are from the patent.
These ellipses, well they have different
thickness, but more importantly,
they have different orientations.
So you can just take a look at
the orientation in a little local area,
of these little dots that
have been smeared, and
the orientation tells you the depth.
This is really, really cool.
But I think it's so
cool that they probably don't use it.
because I think it requires some pretty
precise lensing and some other things.
I'm not, not really sure.
But this is the,
the one method of how the Kinect works.
And if you go in their patent, you'll
see figures that talk about like this,
that you capture this test image and
then you find the range base
upon the pattern orientation.
And then you build this 3D map.
Although you notice this says
based on offsets between test and
reference pattern.
So that's the method
I'm about to tell you.
Here's the one that just talks
about the, the, orientation.